[Music]
millions of people not breathing so easy
this Tuesday night wildfires are
worsening air quality in Canada and the
US oh my God my throat's burning the
concerns about what's to come the role
of climate change and the advice to
anyone Outdoors
a huge Dam in Ukraine collapses the
thousands forced to flee and the
questions about who's to blame
Prince Harry cross-examined his case
against British tabloids and why he
feels he can't trust anybody
now on par the surprise merger ending a
major feud in the golfing world
and from shamed to Showcase not a lot of
people from where I'm from get these
opportunities the Revival of ribbon
skirts
global national with Donna Friesen for
tens of millions of people there is no
escape from the effects of Canada's
explosive wildfires smoke is blanketing
multiple cities Toronto Ottawa Montreal
New York City and Washington D.C all
shrouded in a thick veil of smoke that
has reduced air quality and could stick
around for some time good evening and
thanks for joining us we take clean air
for granted in Canada and these
wildfires are a wake-up call even if
you're not threatened with flames the
choking smoke can still affect you air
quality in some of North America's
biggest cities has plummeted and
warnings are in place for tens of
millions of people where conditions are
the worst seen on this map in purple and
red this afternoon both Toronto and New
York City were ranked among the 10 major
cities with the worst air quality in the
world and it's even worse in many
surrounding communities it's coming from
the more than 100 blazes burning out of
control in Quebec love more on that in a
moment but we begin with Eric Sorensen
and the health effects of all that smoke
in the span of several hours the
nation's capital went from sunny and
clear to hazy and smoke-filled kids
soccer matches were called off and many
are staying indoors I walked to get
coffee in a croissant I'm like oh my God
my throat's burning Riley Schnur is back
to wearing a mask I feel more out of
breath but I mean the mask obviously
helps a little bit but yeah it's more
just like concerning I think to see
the city looking like this the air
quality in much of eastern Ontario was
declared high risk especially for those
who are susceptible respiratory symptoms
hospitalizations asthma exacerbations
and in that broader population will also
have more folks who are particularly
vulnerable to experiencing those effects
the Smoky Haze is not only covering
large areas of the country it's pushing
into densely populated cities the smoke
is sweeping south from forest fires in
Quebec affecting Toronto Montreal Ottawa
but it's continuing on into the
northeastern U.S affecting even more
people today the New York City skyline
looked a lot like the Toronto skyline
the U.S and Canada's most populous
cities Awash in Hayes the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
forecasts more smoke blowing down over
Southern Ontario in the next day if it's
getting worse in the next 24 or 48 hours
it's going to be really bad it's quite
staggering the fire and smoke May
subside but the long-term Outlook is
worrying climate change is bringing
hotter days and a longer Wildfire season
that means more people will require
treatment in the short term and more
will develop respiratory problems long
term further taxing the Health Care
System those fires are you know creating
this air quality and health hazard which
you know will add up to long-term public
health challenges
but it's also emitting a lot of
greenhouse gases at the same time in
short climate change isn't only warming
the air but causing more frequent
wildfires that pollute the Clean Air we
need to remain healthy we need to
confront issues of both climate change
and air pollution together in order to
reduce our risks from air quality there
seems to be heightened awareness of the
role played by climate change I think
we're in big trouble this early in the
year for this to happen big trouble of
course it's a health issue if in fact
I'm inhaling stuff that I shouldn't be
inhaling millions of Canadians are now
dealing with Smoky air while it lasts
the advice is to spend more time indoors
and don't exert yourself if you're
Outdoors Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
roughly 150 fires are raging in Quebec
most of them out of control in BC this
fire on Vancouver Island near Port
Alberni is still spreading it's under
investigation but it's believed to be
human cause and there are 47 active
fires in Ontario including this one near
chaplow in Nova Scotia news cameras were
LED in today to see the destruction
caused by the upper tantalon fire homes
reduced Ash cars melted Mike Armstrong
now on areas recovering from the
destruction
there are parts of what happened that
almost don't make sense this was the
first time a camera was allowed to film
the devastation left by the upper 10
Talon fire outside Halifax with that
camera captured were scenes like this a
home still standing beside burned out
cars and a home left in ashes beside an
intact child's swing set
more of the evacuated area is being
reopened but authorities are asking the
Curious public to stay away if you don't
need to be there please do not be there
there's a lot of Devastation out this
way and it's difficult for families
there is good news in setsel Quebec on
the province's North Shore the fire that
forced 4 000 people to leave their homes
has been dampened by recent rain and
turned with new winds
that evacuation order was lifted Tuesday
that said the fire is still burning it
will take weeks before we stop that but
there's not much population
in this area
the most concerning area for Quebec is
the western part of the province there
are 78 fires in the region and crews are
only able to work on 12.
there is some help on the way close to a
hundred newly trained firefighters hit
the ground Wednesday and the situation
in New Brunswick has improved enough
it's able to send Quebec 42 firefighters
the forecast however isn't good it's
going to be sunny for the next three
four five days so it's going to be
complicated for sure for the next week
in British Columbia there is already
more terrain burned this year than in
all of 2022 the Donny Creek Fire in the
northern part of the province is being
called the second biggest in provincial
history we do anticipate we will be
fighting this fire
um in the weeks and possibly in the
months to come now winds should die down
in the coming days but there's still
little rain in the forecast the fire
will likely get bigger before it gets
better Mike Armstrong Global News
[Music]
this huge Dam in southern Ukraine has
collapsed sending a torrent of water
rushing down the danipro river into
cities and towns up to 80 communities
could be affected by the catastrophic
flooding the dam is critical it provides
water to farms and residents in Ukraine
and helps cool the zaparesian nuclear
power plant what happened while Ukraine
and Russia are both blaming each other
as Crystal gemancing Reports the
priority is saving lives
wading through flood waters that could
contain anything from debris to dislodge
landmines more than 1 000 people from
hersan region were rescued by Tuesday
afternoon
primarily coastal areas of villages
Coastal streets there the water Rose
Somewhere by five meters there were
areas where it Rose to Under The Roof
said Hassan's Regional military
Administration spokesperson speaking
through a translator Alexander
tolokonikov said homes can be replaced
many are being destroyed by regular
Russian attacks protecting lives is the
priority with the attack on the Kahoka
Dam which crosses the danipro river 17
000 people in ukrainian-controlled
territory may need to be moved to safety
this is yet another example of the
horrific consequences of Russia's
illegal invasion of Ukraine during the
course of Russia's full-scale Invasion
it has a repeatedly targeted civilian
infrastructure proof of the early
morning attack has most likely been
washed away but Ukraine says its working
defined CCTV images to prove Russia is
responsible
Russia's defense Ministry says it was
the Kiev regime that committed yet
another terrorist crime unlikely says
this expert of International Security
it's really hard to see how there could
be a Strategic Benefit for Ukraine that
cuts off the bridge and the road and
they've created a situation for the long
term that if Ukraine were to take back
territory that they would have a problem
on their hands the reservoir is one of
the largest in Ukraine IT Supplies water
for agriculture and residents including
those those in Crimea which Russia
illegally annexed in 2014. the reservoir
is also the main water supply used to
cool the nuclear reactors at the
zeparizio power plant as well as the
backup generators the head of the
international atomic energy agency says
based on laws calculations there is
currently enough water there to last for
a couple of days and a backup water
supply is being worked on Raphael Grossi
says he will take a trip to visit the
occupied nuclear power plant next week
and he is calling that visit critical
Donna all right crystal gomancing in
London thank you at least three people
were killed in an earthquake in southern
Haiti today just days after flooding
killed 42 people
site
gathers around this collapsed home
trying to find survivors the 4.9
magnitude Quake struck Just Before Dawn
near the city of Jeremy Haiti was
already struggling to recover from
flooding caused by torrential rain more
than 13 thousand homes were damaged this
Hospital flooded muddy water filling
waiting rooms and hallways one woman
said she lost her five-year-old child 80
has increasingly been in crisis since
the assassination of the president in
2021 in the country is also dealing with
enormous humanitarian and economic
challenges along with extreme gang
violence
Canada's former Governor General David
Johnston was front and center today
grilled for more than three hours over
why he ruled out a public inquiry into
allegations of foreign interference in
question period opposition MPS
questioned his Integrity by putting a
former member of the Trudeau foundation
in this terrible position and
surrounding him with liberal staffers
liberal owner donors and liberal lawyers
he has ruined the perceived objectivity
caused a conflict of interest one that
he could reverse anytime why will the
Prime Minister not put an end to the
charade launch a full public inquiry now
I knew that his judgment was top-notch
and that is what he is
demonstrated every step of the way the
Judgment that is in question is a
judgment of the leader of the opposition
who continues to refuse to get briefed
up on top secret matters that would
allow him to understand what's actually
going on in foreign interference instead
of making faceless personal attacks
Johnston says a public inquiry is
impossible because it would risk
breaching the trust of Canada's security
allies and could endanger intelligence
sources and he rejected allegations he's
biased David Aiken followed the
testimony closely today David the
opposition seems to keep hammering the
same point
well Donna for weeks now the opposition
has objected to David Johnson's work on
foreign interference because of what
they see as too close a personal
relationship with the Prime Minister you
talked of knowing Justin Trudeau since
he was six years old as both families
shared adjacent Cottages in the
laurentians in 2017 sir the Prime
Minister paid tribute to you calling you
a family friend and a friend of his
father liberals on the committee sharply
criticized the conservatives for their
attack on David Johnson's Integrity it
was nothing more than
a character assassination or conspiracy
theories but it was not just the
conservatives the block quebecois and
the NDP joined them by zeroing in on the
lead counsel the lawyer that Johnston
hired to help with his inquiry Sheila
block public records show block has
donated thousands of dollars to the
federal Liberal Party the fact that the
lead Council repeatedly donated to the
liberal party and attended a fundraiser
with the Prime Minister as late as 2021
that this appearance of bias to a
reasonable person would undermine the
work that you're hoping to do I do not
see a conflict
see the block is a preeminent Council
MPS also questioned Johnston as to why
his report failed to mention the Trudeau
foundation and why he failed to
interview MP Han dong or why he failed
to mention the so-called Chinese police
stations in Canada Johnson for his part
said those topics were not critical to
the central issue MPS should focus on
I'm anxious that we get to the real
issue here which is foreign interference
let's look at this report with our
recommendations let's review it and
let's move with urgency on dealing with
a problem which is very very serious but
opposition MP say that's precisely why a
public inquiry is required how on Earth
are we to get the answers we need
to play our constitutional role and hold
this government accountable now as for
prime minister Justin Trudeau he is
standing by Johnson he wants Johnson to
complete a round of public hearings this
Summer that Johnson said have been set
up to find better ways to spot foreign
interference and defend against it Donna
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
Prince Harry taking on the tabloids
coming up his testimony against
newspapers he says hacked his phone
foreign
it's not every day you see a prince
being cross-examined in a courtroom but
Britain's Prince Harry is determined to
take on a tabloid newspaper who he
claims hacked his phone and in a packed
London courtroom today he faced five
hours of tough questions Redmond Shannon
explains what happened
this case he's one of three Prince Harry
is taking against British tabloids whose
Behavior he describes as vile part of
his Crusade against a media he blames
for the death of his mother Princess
Diana the suit hinges on how the mirror
group of newspapers gathered stories
about him and other celebrities dating
back to when he was a Schoolboy and up
until 2011. he says it was done
illegally primarily through hacking
voicemails the mirror group admits to
doing it to other people but not to
Harry and the current claimants in
Tuesday's witness statement Harry
detailed news stories like when he was
spotted picking up his then girlfriend
Chelsea Davey at the airport saying I
recall thinking how on Earth did they
know I was going to be there but now
it's obvious he accuses former Daily
Mirror editor Pierce Morgan of
intimidating him and his wife The
Duchess of Sussex in retaliation for
taking this case saying he wants to hold
Morgan properly accountable for his
unlawful activity towards both me and my
mother during his editorship and in a
remarkable passage for a senior Royal
Harry said our country is judged
globally by the state of our press and
our government both of which I believe
are at rock bottom the the
cross-examination was was fierce as
you'd expect him to be Harry himself was
he was calm he was called Steve Barnett
is a press reform Advocate who was in
the court he says the Duke is in a
unique position to push for changes in
the industry then as far as he's
concerned he's got nothing to lose you
know any skeletons that he may have had
have long been thrown out of the
cupboard the Duke will be back here for
more testimony on Wednesday the case is
expected to run until the end of the
month Donna
Redmond Shannon thank you
construction catastrophe ahead the
bridge in India
they built
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
to a bridge that's being rebuilt in
India the suspension bridge collapsed
for a second time in just over a year
the three kilometer bridge fell into the
Ganges River leaving a huge cloud of
dust and debris Witnesses say they felt
Tremors as it went down there are
reports one person is missing and the
government has launched an investigation
they were rivaled in a bitter Feud and
now they've swung over to being Partners
the PGA and the European tour have
announced they are emerging with live
golf the league bankrolled by billions
of dollars from Saudi Arabia's Sovereign
wealth fund Canadian PGA player
Mackenzie Hughes expressed surprise
about it tweeting nothing like finding
out through Twitter that were merging
others with the tours such as American
Pro Wesley Bryan criticized the deal
saying I feel betrayed and will not be
able to trust anyone within the
corporate structure of the PGA tour for
a very long time meanwhile live golfers
like Phil Mickelson seem thrilled by it
calling it an awesome day live golf was
founded in 22 21 by Saudi Arabia the
latest move in a bid to be a global
sports player that paid several
high-profile golfers from the PGA
hundreds of millions of dollars to win
them over
indigenous identity next the importance
and the power behind the ribbon skirt
[Music]
it's not often a piece of clothing can
be a symbol of resilience survival and
identity that's what a ribbon skirt is
and they're being worn more and more by
indigenous women in their day-to-day
lives to Mark indigenous History Month
Global's Melissa ridgeen speaks with a
Manitoba woman whose designs are gaining
worldwide attention
there was a time these would only be
seen in ceremonies and private
celebrations one of the many casualties
of the residential school system the
pride of wearing one in public stolen
but there's been a colorful Revival even
on International Fashion catwalks
Designer Alicia Sutherland showed her
work in Cannes France last month I can't
believe I'm here I'm able to Showcase my
work I was just trying so hard not to be
emotional because
you know this not a lot of people from
where I'm from get these opportunities
she runs her business on pegua's First
Nation 150 kilometers Northwest of
Winnipeg when my mother-in-law
introduced sewing I was like I think
this is who I am I think this is what I
can create skirt protocols can vary by
Nation Clan or family some have colors
chosen by an elder they're always modest
in length though the longest touching
the ground to connect with Mother Earth
Sutherlands pieces honor the past with
modern Flair and she's paying it forward
teaching a new generation the craft of
her ancestors it made me happy making it
felt good to make it it was a young girl
who put ribbon skirts in the National
Spotlight back in 2020
twelve-year-old Isabella kulak was
shamed by a staff member at a cam Sac
Saskatchewan school for wearing one it
sparked an uprising and ultimately
National ribbon skirt day was celebrated
for the first time ever this past
January for Reuben skirts for me is not
just having ribbon skirts for ceremonies
I want to now wear ribbon skirts every
day in a way and it's kind of like
identity empowerment strength and know
that I'm I'm a warrior wondering if you
can wear a ribbon skirt many designers
say yes if made by First Nations
creators and Warren as an ally as long
as you have a good mindset and a good
way of wearing it to resemble that you
stand with us yes I'm okay with that
Melissa Ridge in Global News Winnipeg
that's global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna freeze